♪ ♪
SPECIES FIVE THE BILLIONAIRE
PUTTING HIS MONEY WHERE HIS
MOUTH IS, THE FOUNDER OF
PATAGONIA'S GIVING HIS COMPANY
AWAY.
IT'S WORTH $3 MILLION, HIS GOAL
IS TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
INSTEAD OF SELLING THE COMPANY
ARE TAKING THE BRAND PUBLIC, HE
IS GIVING IT AWAY.
IVAN CHOUINARD TRANSFERRED HIS
NEARLY 50-YEAR-OLD OUTDOOR
CLOTHING BRAND INTO A TRUST AND
A NONPROFIT.
GET THIS, HIS KIDS WERE OFFERED
BUT DID NOT WANT THE COMPANY
WHERE THEY BOTH STILL WORK.
IN A LETTER ABOUT THE DECISION
HE SAYS THAT HE IS REIMAGINING
CAPITALISM.
TO SAVE OUR HOME PLANET.
AND THE EARTH IS NOW OUR ONLY
SHAREHOLDER.
YOU KNOW, JUDGE, YOU CAN
QUESTION HIS JUDGMENT MAY BE BUT
NOT HIS GENEROSITY.
>> Jeanine: I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW --
>> Geraldo: YOU THINK HE HAS
AN ANGLE?
>> Jeanine: I DO BUT THE
ENTIRE BUSINESS PLATFORM -- I
KNOW HE PAID $17 MILLION ON
$3 BILLION BUT THE ENTIRE
BUSINESS PLATFORM IS ABOUT
HELPING THE ENVIRONMENT, RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
WHY ARE THEY TURNING IT INTO A
TRUST?
DOES THAT HELP THEM TAX WISE?
I DON'T KNOW.
I'D HAVE TO SPEAK TO AN ATTORNEY
ABOUT THAT.
>> Geraldo: YOU DON'T REALLY
QUESTION THIS GUY, COME ON?
>> Jeanine: HE GAVE HIS
COMPANY AWAY BUT STILL IT'S A
COMPANY THAT HAS A TRUST AND A
NONPROFIT THEY'RE GOING TO GIVE
MONEY AWAY.
HOW DO YOU KNOW WHERE THE MONEY
IS GOING?
>> Geraldo: I THINK THAT IS
GREED, GREG, STILL GOOD?
>> Greg: IT'S ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS EVER INVENTED
BEER THE COMPANY HAS TO BE IN
TROUBLE HERE THAT'S ALL THERE
IS.
YES, IT IS, HIS KIDS DON'T WANT
IT, THAT'S A SIGN.
NOBODY WEARS PATAGONIA ANYMORE
EXCEPT FOR WEIRD PEOPLE WHO HANG
OUT AT THE PARK WALKING AND
THEIR IMAGINARY DOGS.
HOW CONVENIENT AFTER HE'S MADE
BILLION DOLLARS OF PEOPLE OFF OF
HIS OVER TRAIPSED GUARD STARTING
CAMPFIRES AND BEATING TRAILS
INTO THE PRISTINE WILDERNESS.
THEN YOU KILL ASSORTED FISH AND
GAME AND NOW YOU WANT TO GIVE UP
THE COMPANY?
BECAUSE YOU'RE OLD.
YOU MADE ALL OF YOUR MONEY.
NOW LOOK HOW GREAT -- SHUT UP!
>> Geraldo: HE USES
SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTS.
AREN'T WE HYPER SUSPICIOUS NOW?
>> Dana: I DON'T CARE WHAT HE
DOES WITH HIS COMPANY.
I DON'T CARE.
I THINK THE CHILDREN DON'T WANT
THE COMPANY, BUT I HAVE A
FEELING THEY PROBABLY NEVER NEED
TO WORK A DAY IN THEIR LIFE
ANYWAY SO I'M SURE THIS IS PART
OF THE STRUCTURING THAT THEY ARE
NOT -- THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
HOMELESS OUT OF THIS.
THE OTHER THING IS -- MAKES MUCH
BETTER CLOTHING ANYWAY.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS THIS IS
NOTHING IN REGARDS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
YOU CAN FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
NOBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
CHINA.
CHINA IS BUILDING TEN NUCLEAR --
COAL FIRE POWER PLANTS A WEEK
AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO
ANYTHING UNTIL 2030 TO START
REDUCING EMISSIONS LIKE WE
BELIEVE THEY WILL EVEN DO THAT.
I JUST HAVE TO READ THIS, FROM A
CLIMATE SCIENTIST THIS IS WHAT
HE SAID.
IMAGINE IF EVERY BILLIONAIRE DID
THIS.
IT WOULD BE THE END OF
CAPITALISM.
ALSO I BET IT FEELS FANTASTIC.
THOSE BILLIONS HAVE TO BE CHAINS
WEIGHING DOWN THE SOUL YOU'RE
THE MOST BILLIONAIRES DON'T EVEN
REALIZE THAT THEY BECOME
ADDICTED INSTEAD.
THIS IS ABOUT FEELINGS.
>> Geraldo: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT GUY.
HE DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A LOT OF
FUN TO HANG OUT WITH.
GUESS HOW MUCH JEFF BEZOS GAVE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE CHARITY?
>> Greg: LETS GO $10 BILLION.
>> Geraldo: NO JUST
$2 BILLION.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A LOT OF.
>> Greg: WHAT IS HE WORTH?
>> Geraldo: I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Jesse: THE KNEES CHEAP.
YOU KNOW I FEEL BAD FOR?
THE RIGHTFUL HEIRS.
THEY DIDN'T ASK THE GRANDSONS.
IF YOU ARE A GRANDCHILD AND YOU
ARE SITTING ON A FORTUNE IN YOUR
FUTURE AND YOUR GRANDFATHER AND
FATHER GIVE IT AWAY TO SOME
TRUST YOU'LL NEVER HAVE ACCESS
TO, I MEAN THAT IS A LAWSUIT
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
I'M GOING TO BLOW YOUR MIND,
GERALDO, PREPARE TO HAVE YOUR
MIND BLOWN.
REMEMBER HOW WE SHUT DOWN THE
ENTIRE GLOBAL ECONOMY FOR ABOUT
15-20 MONTHS?
DO YOU THINK THE AMOUNT OF
CARBON DIOXIDE IN THE AIR
INCREASED OR DECREASED?
>> Geraldo: NO IDEA.
>> Jesse: IT INCREASED!
WE DID EVERYTHING THE LIBERALS
WANTED.
WE SHUT DOWN FACTORIES, PEOPLE
STOP DRIVING TO WORK, AIRPLANES
WEREN'T FLYING, EVERYTHING SHUT
DOWN.
AND CARBON DIOXIDE IN THE AIR
INCREASED.
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THIS ALL
WRONG, GERALDO.
>> Geraldo: THE THING ABOUT
INHERITANCE IS THERE IS NO MORE
BITTER FIGHT THEN OVER ON THE
EARNED MONEY.